in this episode we're going to build a
to-do list feature that performs the
sequel style cred of create read update
and delete no sequel uses different
terms through these operations so here's
a basic translation when working with
firebase create equals push read equals
list or object update equals update or
set and delete equals remove angular
apps work with asynchronous data streams
using rxjs or reactive extensions for
JavaScript the data stream can be pretty
much anything but in this context we're
talking about objects from the firebase
real time database
at this point it's assumed you have the
angular fire to package installed and
bootstrapped into your app if not go to
the docs or check out our environment
setup video start by generating the
necessary files from the command line
the feature is just a simple list of
to-do items that can be modified by
users we will give items their own type
script class to keep our data nice and
organized all the crud metric happens in
the service which is going to perform
six different operations it can get a
list of items get a single item create a
new item update an existing item the
we'd an existing item and delete an
entire list of items start by importing
dependencies and declaring a couple
public variables when we get an item or
list of items they will be returned as
an observable which can then be
unwrapped asynchronously from the
component the functions for getting an
item or list will return the observable
so it can then be set to a public
variable all other functions are going
to return void because they operate on
the items variable or take a specific
key as an argument any component
watching the items variable will be
automatically updated when these
functions are called from a component
all of these operations are defined on
the angularfire to Doc's so I recommend
you check those out if you're looking
for more specific details on one of
these functions the list component will
serve as the parent component that
iterates over items in the database
first we need to define a public items
variable during the ng on a net life
cycle hook this variable is going to
hold the firebase to list observable
then we use the ng for directive in the
template along with the async pipe to
iterate over the observable the async
pipe is critical because the observable
will be empty on initial rendering so we
need to tell angular to handle it
differently than just plain JavaScript
object in the item detail component we
use the input decorator to pass data
from the parent to the child via the
template we also create a few functions
that can be triggered by clicking button
to operate on a single item within the
list in the template itself we display
the item attributes and add the crud
functions to the corresponding buttons
angular has several different form
validation methods but in this example
I'm going to use that template driven
approach that uses the if-then-else
syntax introduced in angular 4 this
method is only ideal for small simple
forms because all the logic is going to
be defined directly in the HTML which
tends to be harder to maintain than just
regular type script
[Music]
we define two different templates named
valid and errors we can then display
these templates conditionally based on
the form state the final step is to
submit the form to create a new item in
this case I just use the click event to
trigger the create item method from the
service that's all for firebase cred see
you next time
[Music]